good to be back um what were you going
to say it's my opener
it is
what i was going to say oh what i want
to say is that so when we when i came in
here everyone is in a bad mood everyone
is tired everyone's friends dodgers are
down the dodgers are down again you know
it's all games they're losing
yeah they're talking i know shut up rick
that sucks they're
they're part of the culture they are the
american dream
correct you know i think it's language
like that that kind of separates us as
if our dreams are better or more
important i think it's just a dream to
be successful at what you do i agree
right and to bring others joy yeah
yeah so are you reiterating throwing out
or
putting down
speaking of putting down how come you
weren't working much when you guys first
started what was going on what do you
think changed
things okay
i was out
i was on the streets like can i finish
my point man yes all right
so um
back to so back in the day right there
was a point where it's like
you go i was playing a lot of video
games down here right and then you were
like we don't get to spend a lot of time
with each other right so then i brought
the video game system up to the bedroom
right so that i can be around you but
that's not what you were talking about
about what intimacy about intimacy no
but why can't i play video games and do
intimacy at the same time
intimacy would involve you not holding a
xbox controller
why
what do you think rick i think if you
connected through xbox as well perhaps
it could
so you're saying i should
i'm saying
we all have our languages
and bobby assumes that you have his
but you are also saying that his isn't
important his is very important he's
taken care of what are what where do i
lack
tell me in what way the camera's off
what are you doing right now
yeah but true question in the eight
years we've been together
what are things you feel as though i
lack at that i could do more for you
nothing
i feel good
yeah yeah
nothing
that must feel good
it really is i can't think of one okay
yeah yeah and there's a million things
that i could do for
you name five
how would i put a number to it okay just
because the pressure of five five right
ten
[Laughter]
um
intimacy what does intimacy mean to you
um to be present with you
to ask about your day really ask right
ask how you feel how you are in the
moment
um when i work together
when we're holding each other and
cuddling right is this that i'm not on
my gadgets then that that my intention
my attention is fully on you
right that's something you desire right
also you would like for me to
know more about you in terms of things
that you love and your aspire and your
dreams and your feelings you want me to
know those things right i know them i
know them right um about your spear
fishing and all that stuff you want me
to know about it well
not all of it i know i'm just saying
right like you get upset when i um when
you send me a photo of you're spearing
an innocent little fishy
in the ocean no i sent you a video of me
swimming with dolphins and he left me on
red
right and it's there's a study that was
i've seen it before i've seen the
dolphin such a metaphor when someone
leaves you on red it kind of leaves
you on red you know like you kind of
just get hot and
hey can you cut that part out where i
seen it before i've seen it can you cut
that part out yeah fine if you cut that
part out
then
cut out uh when i said art instead of
out
keep it all in you gotta keep it all in
now yeah
that's the art
no because when i did that my anyway
when i did my thing it just came out of
left field sure
speaking of which the dodgers really
need to get no margosa piara or somebody
to play left i know emmanuel amamura
yeah i'm not gonna work here anymore
that's for sure yeah is that
anyway you named one but that was really
but that's a big one that's the biggest
one that's the only one that's not the
only one what's in the second one
personal hygiene oh that's right stop
stop
personal hygiene
you know bobby bobby yeah bobby i gotta
say that
it doesn't seem like you're wanting
kalila to feel heard as much as proving
that you know what's best
and you're almost regurgitating
the rules instead of accepting the
reality i i don't know what do you think
about that
i think you're on to something rick i
think you're
off off the charts
you're not even in the ballpark the dogs
are the dodgers yeah the duck oh what do
you think the dodgers need to do
they need to just
they need to keep their eye on the prize
if there's if there's
if there's a guy in scoring position a
pop-up fly
would be just fine you can't put guys
out there and not turn it over into runs
i'll tell you what i'm saying let me
tell you what i think i think we should
just stop let me i really have a thought
on this i i i i'm gonna let you say it
but can i just say something what do you
guys think
yeah but who's the boss
who's the boss
i'm the boss right so can the boss say
something
what do you think
two one thank you
start from five five start from ten
yes they're for twenty there's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's [ __ ]
i'm the boss do twenty there should be a
disclaimer up front before anyone
listens to the show that this is very
seizure inducing i know it's seizures
is seizures
that's the case and
that sucks count from 20 i said
20 19 18 17. i'm kidding so let's say
let me say something i'm the boss okay
it's we